fans of american pickers were shocked
when frank fritz suddenly departed the
show in 2021 did he really leave on bad
terms and what was his life like before
the hit series keep watching to find out
although antiquing may seem like a hobby
for older people looking to reminisce
about the past a passion for collecting
can develop at any age for renowned
picker frank fritz the desire to start
collecting began as a kid he told
sidewalks entertainment
you know i collected all the staples
when i was a kid and it just escalated
he recalled collecting beer cans stamps
coins and razor blades and his passion
for beer cans continued through his
career becoming one of his signature
finds on the show fritz continued to
collect through his adolescence moving
on to big ticket items like motorcycles
and dirt bikes started out buying dirt
bikes like it was mini bikes and i went
to bigger motorcycles although he
enjoyed the hobby he didn't pursue
antiquing as a career after graduating
from high school it wouldn't be until
about 25 years later that he'd begin his
journey into becoming a picker
although their relationship may seem
strained now the natural chemistry
between fritz and costar mike wolfe
wasn't entirely staged for the show the
dynamic duo knew each other long before
any cameras started rolling brits and
wolf met in middle school and both
graduated from high school in iowa which
is where their shared passion for
picking blossomed however fritz told the
sun that the two weren't necessarily
friends right off the bat although they
both began collecting his children it
was wolf who initially started recording
himself while antiquing and pitching the
idea for the show to different networks
according to southeastern antiquing and
collecting magazine that's a good day to
be a picker wolff had to convince fritz
to join him in his videos this meant
leaving behind fritz's brick and mortar
antique store frank's finds where he
primarily sold firehouse memorabilia and
collectibles
after fritz agreed the two would drive
around and record themselves on the way
to picking sites finally i catch a break
aside from being an antique collector
reality star and entrepreneur fritz is
also an avid vintage motorcycle fan as a
teenager one of his first antique
purchases was a 1964 harley-davidson
much to the dismay of his parents
he now owns a barn filled with vintage
motorcycles and using his knowledge of
bikes for its published how to pick
vintage motorcycles three years after
the debut of american pickers the guide
explains how to find bikes negotiate
prices and maintenance after purchase
i mean does it have a title is the frame
cracked on it what's the brakes look
like fritz is also a contributing author
on american picker's guide to picking
the sixth chapter book acts as a
companion to the television show going
into depth on specific episodes it also
offers tips and tricks for anyone
interested in getting into picking and
collecting antiques
fans didn't know what to expect
following fritz's sudden disappearance
from the show i need a break but no one
could have foreseen the controversy that
erupted between the two childhood
friends
according to entertainment weekly wolf
expressed his condolences for his
longtime friends firing in a statement
saying in part
i will miss frank just like all of you
and i pray for the very best and all
good things for him on the next part of
his journey
but his involvement in fritz's departure
didn't stop there in response to wolf's
statement fritz spoke to the sun
claiming that he'd never had a good
relationship with his co-star and adding
mike's statement was bull
somebody wrote it out for him
still it seems like the biggest issue
between the two pickers was a lack of
communicating during fritz's hiatus for
the show fritz told the sun that his
co-star never called to check in on him
following a major back surgery which
left him with 185 stitches and two rods
in his back he alleged he knows i hurt
my back everyone in the whole network
knew i hurt my back but did one person
just one call and see how i was no no no
no no
fritz has always been relatively private
when it comes to his personal life but
sometimes personal issues get too big to
hide before he was officially off
american pickers he took time off for a
serious back surgery and went public
with his decision to enter rehab for
alcohol abuse he entered a treatment
facility in iowa for 77 days according
to the sun he spoke about the reasoning
behind his decision saying i didn't like
drinking anymore my mom was an alcoholic
and she died five years ago and it was
alcohol related my grandfather was an
alcoholic and he died that didn't sit
well with me but that's not the first
time fritz's substance abuse was in the
news in 2017 fritz was arrested after
driving the wrong way on the iowa
interstate he was charged with an owi
and admitted to drinking and taking a
dose of xanax before getting behind the
wheel according to wqad it was fritz's
first offense
fritz has been public with his ongoing
health issues especially his battle with
crohn's disease which is a type of
inflammatory bowel disease that can
cause serious health complications
including weight loss abdominal pain
dehydration and anemia there's no cure
for it although it's often treated with
steroids or immunosuppressants in 2013
fans began to question fritz's sudden
weight loss following a brief hiatus
during seasons 8 and 9. to avoid any
rumors he spoke openly about his
diagnosis on social media saying i have
an illness called crohn's disease which
at times is difficult to deal with i
started losing weight and ran with it
fritz spoke with the sun to explain that
he had lost 65 pounds due to a change in
diet to help manage his symptoms
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]